and eight on your side tonight can women
really tackle it all and feel fulfilled
frankly who says we have to handle it
all we caught up with mother of two and
tedx speaker Vanessa loader who has
supported thousands of women feeling
burned out she can speak to the signs of
it and how to address the real problem
Vanessa Loda worked in Corporate America
on Wall Street in Silicon Valley and I
got to the top of the ladder and I
didn't have all the happiness and joy
and satisfaction and inner peace that I
thought I would have and so I had you
know a bit of a breakdown of my own she
started studying mindfulness and the
Neuroscience behind Behavior change ways
to rewire our response to stress and
started questioning a lot of the shoulds
running her life this question of can
women have it all I think what's
underneath that is the implication that
women should do it all for everyone else
all the time which is not healthy or
realistic and leads to burnout how can
you identify when you've hit that point
you're frequently on edge overwhelmingly
exhausted and not engaged at work but
don't think changing your job is going
to solve the problem happiness and
satisfaction and a feeling of calm we
think we can get these from outside
circumstances or if I quit this job and
go over there like The Grass Is Always
Greener but in the end we cultivate
those States from the inside out
changing your mindset beliefs and
actions will create more of that inner
peace and happiness you seek in your
life she calls it finding your energetic
breadcrumb like some part of you jumps
out of your body at excitement about
that thing that's an energetic
breadcrumb and so when you start to pay
attention to those and follow them that
will lead you to a more satisfying
fulfilling life
Vanessa has a ton of other tips she
shares in her book The Sole solution to
God for brilliant overwhelmed women to
quiet the noise and their superpower to
find it and finally feel satisfied you
can find it on Amazon